welcome back to the show thanks for
hanging with us at the break uh we have
a special guest with us here today
dakota adams he's been here before
dakota how are you
doing just fine i'm feeling very slick
today good yeah you look he looks like
look look suave yeah yeah nice jacket
too nice jacket yep i came in uh
accidentally dressed like i'm at the
comic book store and i have a lot of
opinions about woke marvel that i want
to share with you
my costume for the day well i i wish we
could talk about
i had questions about woke marvel or
woke disney but those are not the
questions i have for you today i have a
couple subjects that i've been wanting
to ask you about over the last few weeks
um the first off i want to ask you about
jason von tattenhoven um he was a he was
he used to be an oath keeper he's been
doing some interviews lately trying to
distance himself from the oath keepers
now you know jason correct yes uh we
hung out with him quite a bit he was out
keepers a main pr guy
for i believe two years
uh lived in our town
uh worked closely with stuart over at
our house all the time and on and we're
both in local emergency services he was
on search and rescue so i got to know
him pretty well his split with the oath
keepers i want to ask about that but
first off
do you think we're going to see more and
more uh
prior oath keepers or you know veteran
oath keepers as it were distance
themselves from this group as more and
more about this seditious conspiracy
comes out and starts to play out with
some of the conviction and not not just
the indictments but also some of the
plea deals that have been had do you
think that's gonna happen more and more
i think it's going to happen some more
but it's not going to be a huge number
because a large number of the people
that are not okay with the direction of
keepers went they split well in the past
a lot of the people that would have been
coming out as ex-health keepers or
especially had splinter groups
um think talking more like people who
split her away and disavow health
keepers
during the ferguson riots
and afterwards when the militia aspect
started to become more pronounced
so there's going to be some people who
held on for a while
and are now disavowing oath keepers
but this but most of the people just
about oath keepers they long since did
that and a bunch of them
are still not going to be friendly with
what they perceive as
uh leftist or
uh
mainstream aligned media and won't be
speaking with anybody except like
revolver anywhere right right
so why do you think the the sudden
change you said he was the pr guy so he
was in there for two years like so why
do you think the sudden change of heart
or like uh
the the reinventing or whatever you want
to call it um why do you think like now
all of a sudden well from looking at his
twitter he's been trying to build a
different life outside of oath keepers
for a while and i genuinely hope it goes
well for him because aside from sticking
up for stuart
in the past
it never really
done anything wrong aside from being
involved in oath keepers when it looked
more like a legitimate organization
but i think now that oath keepers is a
big thing he's basically just trying to
get his name out there
okay so you think he might be
capitalizing off the uh
the oath keepers being in the news and
he was a former member the pr guy
because apparently um
there's a story that that stuart
actually lived on this guy's couch for a
while yes he lived in a he lived in a
basement room
in this guy's house and might have been
instrumental in getting this guy
actually evicted
from his house in eureka because they
trashed it so thoroughly and from what i
understood um a big part of that was the
squalor that stewart lives in habitually
it was so bad that
it pushed their landlord into becoming
an early adopter of airbnb
for our area anyway yeah because it was
just it was that was the final straw for
long-term renters
was having to
almost renovate the house after they
were gone and from my personal
experience with stuart if it wasn't
mostly him he was at least a
very contributing factor
to the house being completely trashed so
so was this kind of the split between
stuart and and jason then i mean was
that where it kind of happened
because yeah because the last i know
that
he and tattenhoeven were
uh on speaking terms and hanging out was
when stewart was living in their house
up until
they got evicted now they weren't just
on speaking terms uh tattenhoven
actually um
vouched for stewart apparently in some
of the the ongoing court proceedings
against stewart and your family is that
is that right yes he showed up to a
hearing
as a character witness for stewart the
uh sitting in the waiting room with him
was tremendously awkward and at least
him and one of stuart's little bodyguard
dudes
just trying to make small talk about
wildland fire and how long ago was that
2018 that would have been later on in
2018. so at this point we're looking at
uh almost almost four years now that
that that was that he's been quote
unquote rebuilding his reputation from
some of those points where he was
actually helping stuart so yeah he's
only been doing interviews relatively
recently i believe talking about atoning
for his part in oath keepers but the the
time to speak up and start speaking up
was a while ago right
but now because stuart's in the news and
there's press around oath keepers at
january 6th and
you know it's an opportune time to you
know atone for your sins you know not to
say that maybe he it maybe he is genuine
maybe he is yeah maybe you're a genuine
i don't want to say too much bad about
him because going against
even with stewart indicted going against
a group life goat keepers can
can be scary and maybe he just wanted to
be forgotten about
until it became clear that oath keepers
was not going away right in the news
cycle i'm
trying very hard not to hold a personal
grudge well i i i did see
uh i didn't mean to step on either i did
see that him and tasha your mother
actually had a cordial back and forth on
twitter um about some of the things that
were said and you know i don't i don't
know if there was a conclusion or uh
resolution to that but it is it is at
some point good to see that he's willing
to admit some of the wrongs that he
possibly did and defended for for maybe
quite some time so yeah i mean i think
that was the extent of their contact
you would have to be uh you have to ask
tasha for more details about that all
right because that's basically all that
i know
but that was on
i had to hunt around on twitter to find
that conversation i think he actually
started another twitter account and
abandoned that one
i think people started their
conversation that he knew he was talking
to her because they started with uh her
asking him if he would trust stewart
along with his children
and he said no
right well and it was in like a thread
because i i saw it it was in like a
thread of maybe an interview that he had
done or something um it was in
a thread for an another news article and
then right on his account he's got links
to interview interviews
he chimed in the comments talking and
then
that popped up on my mom's twitter radar
now there is more oath keepers in the
news um we have seen that joshua james
um who is one of the i think the
original 11 that were indicted on uh
seditious conspiracy with stuart um who
apparently and i know you'll probably
tell us more about this that you've read
who it seems like he was almost like
roger stone's personal bodyguard that
day was with him the entire day during
january 6. um but you don't know joshua
james um but tell us what you do what
tell us what you do know about maybe the
oath keepers lending him as a bodyguard
to someone who may have needed
protection that day how that works why
why the oath keepers would do that and
then tell us too because it seems like
there's a chain of command thing going
on where he's standing he's next to
roger
our last interview you talked about uh
stuart being
uh over that have the command over the
qrf so tell us about how some of that
works and if it's even relevant in this
case
i think it's extremely relevant and i
think we're going to see seeing more
weird connections to roger stone
emerging as time goes on i honestly the
uh the screen capture or the the picture
that was taken during that documentary
that showed uh
stuart rhodes in roger stones frequently
contacted on his telegram contacts
you're talking about where it showed his
his telephone screen yes that might have
been it might have been signal app i
can't remember which one it was but it
was uh i expected another layer of
abstraction i expected it
to be someone like joshua james who was
relaying
information from roger stone and back
and forth to stuart if they were in
direct contact with each other i didn't
expect them to be just talking on the
phone right well apparently they
kept it a little bit simpler than i
thought they would have
well and it seems like roger stone is
the only one layer between maybe stuart
rhodes or who whomever and donald trump
because we know we know from prior past
that roger stone and donald trump have
talked about texting each other and
talking on the phone personally on their
personal cell phone so now i don't know
if it was that day
one could only suspect that roger
one could only suspect that roger stone
probably has donald trump's phone number
whether he text him and call him maybe
that's maybe that's something the
january 6th select committee and the
department of justice would be
interested in um
also i i think that's probably fair to
say so yeah in their respective that the
oath keepers because here's the thing
it seemed originally that the proud boys
and i'm going to talk a little more
about the brown boys here in a minute
but it seemed like originally the proud
boys were the one that were gonna
protect roger stone which in our
interview where you and your mom tasha
were you guys kind of said there's a
riff between oath keepers and uh proud
boys possibly um but if if nothing else
a rift that exists inside the head of
stuart rhodes which means that it exists
as far as healthcare is concerned
because stewart's delusions
direct oath keepers right right
well so so
do you think there's any significance in
roger stone bailing
on the proud boys
um
detail and going with joshua james as it
were do you think there's anything
significant about that that he would
choose
to go with oath keepers maybe to have i
mean it seemed like he had a direct line
with it with stuart but maybe to have
that extra contact point i don't know
with the qrf maybe um i genuinely
couldn't guess i have a feeling that
whatever happened that caused that last
minute switch
is weirder
than
any of us would guess at
trying to figure out what happened
behind the scenes there because the
inside of oath keepers operations
chaotic
always always chaotic always a mess but
something stewart really liked to do
was get his guys in there as security
detail for important people is always
offering oath keepers up a security
detail
for important people he had the world's
worst instagram selfie
um escorting women
into the trump ball a stuart stewart was
escorting them yes after does this photo
still exist somewhere you think oh i
think it does it's like
he looks it looks like
it looks like a uh self-portrait of mr
potato head
it's like one quarter of his face
[Laughter]
on like a 2009 flip phone or a
blackberry
in 2016. and he posted it he posted yes
he posted that saying this i we're
escorting
young lady grateful young ladies or
something like that into the maga ball
is there where was this was this in dc
or
i think this this was the maga ball in
dc right after the election
oh okay so that so this was this was
before the insurrection maybe maybe this
one there was uh there was contact to
plan to plan who knows yeah i think this
might have been
the origin point for whoever he had
personal contact with
that was getting him in better and
better with
the trump with the trump people because
that was the first
like before that stuart wasn't getting
invited to cpac or any of this [ __ ]
right well because he kind of had a riff
he had kind of had a riff with trump
right like he he wrote kind of a
manifesto that said [ __ ] trump kind of
thing right i mean he was eventually
critical of trump in this case of the
horrible procrastination worked in his
favor because he never actually wrote
his open letter to donald trump
schooling him on the constitution he
just talked about it a bunch
and it never progressed beyond the draft
stage which made it easier for him to
completely pivot to being
a hardcore
trump fanboy later on when that became
more personally convenient to him and
the fear of hillary the deep
seated fear of hillary clinton being
elected took hold
and and this all stems and we've talked
about this before this all stems from
his fear delusion it may be delusion it
may be reality that that the department
of justice would come after him or the
oath keepers for events that happened uh
during the bundy ranch event is that
correct yes that is absolutely my read
of it because oathkeepers was more
involved
better organized
than
many of the people
especially uh
like
cellular militia group leadership
were charged for their involvement in
bundy ranch
i see i see well i know i know we have
some uh speaking of proud boys in the
rift and um that sort of thing the other
piece of news that we have um
is uh
gabe's favorite favorite proud boy uh
enrique
tario i'm gonna kind of let gabe asking
questions because i know i know tario is
uh gabe's done a few videos on a regular
and uh yeah he's one of gabe's uh
favorite probably so i'll let him ask
but but to to give set the scene here uh
he was he was arrested which is a
hilarious video by the way he was
arrested and indicted also
on uh seditious uh conspiracy charges
now
it seems kind of funny that it would be
proud boys and oath keepers to groups
that may or may not be associated but
gabe uh take it away on any questions
you have about proud boys and eureka
enrique enrique i think is a very
interesting story right he's afro-cuban
he's leader of the proud boys
i know that there's a rift within that
team of like who's really the leader now
you know kind of thing you know he
the thing that took him to jail for five
months where he complained about the
conditions the horrible dc conditions
uh was because he he burned a uh it was
a black lives matter flag and that's
where he got busted yeah didn't he tear
it off didn't he tear it off a church
tear it off a church and then they
brought the church and burned it like of
all the things that he's probably been
associated with that was the thing that
got him in trouble
blatantly doing it and caught himself
got caught himself in 4k and so then
obviously most recently uh
nobody nobody knew right not even his
lawyer had a heads up of of them coming
to arrest him right he get he comes out
at least he had some boxers on
uh we had enrique tario full nips
uh ready to go and get arrested
um but yeah i just think like just this
just just the
the the concept of enrique tario as the
leader of the proud boys is one i think
fascinating in and of itself
but also you know you talked about this
relationship or rather this
uh
fantasy like rift maybe was was in his
was in stuart's mind or not but like
you're jealousy that right uh
gavin mcginnis and other people
associated with the proud boys you get
top billing over him in events
jealousy that trump would give shout
outs to the proud boys
or the important political figures would
give shout outs to the proud boys and he
wouldn't that they got more media
attention
just endless endless jealousy yeah
why do you why do you think trump would
shout them out more sorry give it to me
more publicly visible
because uh trump watches cable news
if you want if you want to know why
trump is talking about a particular
thing it's because it was featured on
fox news that is the most
likely answer to any given question for
why is trump talking about windmills
when somebody asks him about ukraine
it's because he thought on kennedy that
night and that's the only thing in his
head right right which i the other thing
too i mean like he also did give a shout
out during the debates right and it was
like you know will you denounce uh this
group and he's like stand back and stand
by and everyone's like
you know and everyone proud boys and
probably others affiliate maybe those
keepers took it as a signal to
themselves to be like great we are
locked and loaded ready to go whenever
he gives us a signal
the standby the standby signal that
fueled a whole bunch of people
and i think that was very deliberate and
it's very smart it does that
the thing that we keep talking about
when we discuss trump and right-wing
populism and the alt-right and this uh
fascist movement to take control of
america
using
like channels like fox news to signal
boost
is the creation of a set of can the
creation
of a mindset for mob violence or
political violence to be triggered by
keywords
that give the people issuing the order
plausible deniability
right right it's very much like uh like
a sikkim type approach like he has him
ready and he'll you know feed him little
treats here and there and then he you
know whenever he feels like he needs to
give the signal or whenever they feel
like they've interpreted that signal
whatever it might be then they're ready
to they're ready to pounce on on
whatever protect attack you know
whatever whatever that uh
whatever that that disgusting world that
trump has made they you know they feel
like they're validated and they can go
forward with it but i think the other
thing too is
on
uh for with the proud boys is the fact
that like enrique tario is a snitch i
mean like let's just call what it is
right the guy has a record working with
federal and state law enforcement back
in 2013 2014 he has a history so to say
that he won't turn on anyone else to
to lessen his sentence or to get out of
whatever a charges or or time he's
looking at like oh 100 percent you know
like
want to see
will and
i'm
this would need to be double checked
because i'm not 100 certain i believe
there is footage of stuart rhodes and
tario meeting in a parking garage
somewhere
in dc on the day of the six so there's
like cctv
don't you have a video game of
gave us a video uh that he made it's
satire it's satire but it literally is
guys meeting in a parking garage yeah
it's it's fbi it's fbi's setting up for
a drug bust
yeah it's just enrique tario you know
trying to clean the streets off from
from non-white people he wants only
white people and then only to realize
that he himself is not white
it's the same realization candace owens
is going to have someday
oh wait wait she's in the news today but
yeah maybe
couple things couple things i want to go
over here because uh you said a couple
names uh gavin mcginnis because we've
been back and forth with who's the
leader of the proud boys but he's he's
kind of the the uh the originator right
yeah he's the originator and then he
lost it all he was
in the first wave of loud
in your face this is back when they were
calling themselves like the alt-right
right and there was when they were
calling this was the alt-right but also
insisting that the all-right wasn't
racist right uh hot [ __ ] and he was uh
he got his claim to fame was uh
compilations of him just uh
like talking about his college hookups
in the worst way possible
while supposedly debating
supposedly debating a feminist and like
going on joe rogan and being just like
so graphic and weird that it like gave
joe rogan visible pause
and he got um he got famous
as a personality
for that was the celebration uh locker
room talk
worldwide talk let's bring this [ __ ]
into the open we're going to say the
quiet part so [ __ ] loud you won't be
able to not hear it he's also famous for
some other things right yeah well
uh very toxic uh
he was just a little bit too
of much of an early adopter for his own
good because he was still very much
in the
stage of right-wing populism
where you still pretend to be
libertarian or pretend to be centrist or
maybe you are just a little bit and it's
it's all about uh trashing
still about trashing leftism and
feminism and everything else that your
reactionary audience might find icky or
think is funny just because it's
offensive
like that's that's just like the love at
the base level of uh this is hilarious
because it's offensive a dime out about
it
but he still had the reflexive urge to
do kind of centrist hedging
in that
and he
got to admire
the follow-through
of trying to go all the way with both of
those of being as graphic and offensive
and loud and in your face as possible
while insisting that you're not a
homophobic or racist
and this ended up with
i don't want to say following it to its
logical conclusion that's not quite the
right word but the end result was he
decided would be a good idea
to
shove a dildo up his ass on a live
stream to prove that he doesn't hate gay
people well there's he got us he owned
the rice right
[Laughter]
definitely owned them
surprise surprise uh
his audience he might have been already
slipping from the public eye
at that point so it's also a little bit
of a look at me thing but his audience
wasn't really down with that and that
kind of
tilt
his dominance of
the right-wing manosphere and he slid
into obscurity i haven't heard
of anything gavin mcginnis is doing in
like four years right so no longer was
he the mantle of macho machismo at that
point what was that before after
charlottesville because i know i know
charlottesville was uh because
charlottesville kind of put the uh
dagger in the quote-unquote alt-right uh
when they were calling it that before
they re-branded the to something
different that was when uh vanguard
america was pretending to not be
neo-nazis right that's right and the
all-right was pretending not to be
racist and then
the mask kind of fell away
right right so when they had that event
right
still had their shields but they got new
uh uh logos what's what's that what's
the group called now what are they
called patriot front yeah
they put up uh posters that have razor
blades embedded in the back so you cut
yourself if you take them down
they try to co-op other uh right-wing
group marches like they showed up and
crashed
they'll go to march for pro-lifers and
they they run them the [ __ ] off because
they know they're nazis and they're like
yeah you're making us look like nazis we
can't look like not i mean we are nazis
but we can't look like nazis we can't
probably look like nazis we can't
publicly look like that well
um which is probably a breeding ground
also for like this um uh this group
called adam waffen which is uh they're
outright nazis like they admit they're
nazis um i think
that is a successor organization to some
very old
white supremacist groups like the one my
uh father's family married into like old
school
aryan nation types right right right
well and there's even some groups that
are starting some communities i think in
idaho and some other places
that are looking for right-wing places
where neo-nazis used to be they ran them
off and now the right wings kind of
going back to those to those kind of
fell out of favor and out of the public
eye and went i would call it more
dormancy
than anything and uh they're under the
rocks as it were kind of yeah but now
they're scurrying into the daylight but
they're also perceiving because fascism
like
your ideology is that you're always
under threat by some
massively powerful enemy that could be
easily defeated if you just pull the
pull it together and they're they're
still getting if they're still in the uh
waiting for the black helicopters
mindset
and so
like a lot of times idaho
gets glanced over as a small as like a
malicious stronghold and a right-wing
stronghold i know keepers had a very
heavy idaho presence there were a lot of
very well organized state chapters down
there
and as ever
like even with charlottesville if i
am not remembering wrong that was a
second amendment protest that was
well originally it was because of the
statute coming down they wanted to pull
oh no you are you're right that was a
completely different thing that looks
like confederates well
it was the people who love lincoln but
hate lincoln who fly the american flag
but i think lincoln is a great president
it's it's really weird [ __ ] the thin
blanket of being pro-america and the
party of lincoln
desperately wanted a confederacy back so
yes that's where you unite the right
that was unite the right and all that
that so yeah i was thinking of something
completely different but uh no what i
was thinking of was the
which state capital i'm a little bit
burnt out today i've inhaled too many
cat pee fumes doing demolition
hair right before i can that's what the
jacket's about too right yeah that's
what the track
into the least blue collar thing that i
own to distance myself from the smell
[Laughter]
um whichever state capital it was where
they had the massive pro second
amendment march and that was the one
where the base was going to show up and
do a drive-by shooting in blackface and
they got popped by the fbi
i i is this michigan
because i know there's i know there's
big right-wing uh movements in michigan
yeah there was the there was the
michigan state capital had right the
dozens of second amendment rights right
and the other the other thing too is
they they they had the plot the right
wingers had the plot to kidnap the
governor and uh there's been there's
been a lot of uh
several of those most of them sovereign
citizens right because there's a lot of
right-wing militia in michigan right i
mean that's there's a there's a big
brood of them there if you i feel like
michigan should redo their uh their like
travel psa where it's like pure michigan
you know it's like pure
michigan not pure
no it's pure it's like pure white maybe
right right like
well but i mean but i mean maybe that's
maybe that's why the piano yeah it was
true like it was attractive
exactly like oh pierre well hey that
that was right up our alley well not
even going back to the uh like in the
90s like um
like books like uh wesley rawls uh
patriots which is the most god-awful
militia fiction you will ever read they
refer to michigan as militian because
it's a hotbed of resistance against the
new world order and the post collapse
and all this [ __ ] so that's been true
for a long time right right but the
general trend is that whenever there is
a surge
in
standard right-wing activity
neo-nazis will show up and try to co-opt
it and try to recruit
and infiltrate and gain influence there
was a concerted effort organized on
stormfront to infiltrate oath keepers
chapters and try to bring them around to
being racially aware
there are neo-nazis that crash
uh
nominally non-racist militia events
and it was something uh
when i was a kid
militia leaders were very concerned
about was the attempt
by nazis
to gain control of the militia movement
or at least make it look to the outside
like they were gaining control because
that would create a feedback loop but i
guess in the face of
crt
um that's spared abandoned and nobody's
trying nobody's trying to keep the
camel's nose out from underneath the
tent anymore it's long since over with
and that's where
uh you get tons of white supremacists
moving to
um
inside the movement fairly well known
malicious stronghold areas like idaho
and the more nazis move to idaho the
more it gets social media buzz as the
nazi place the more nazis are going to
move there which you know might be nice
to have them all concentrated but you
also don't want them to become a
majority in any one place right lots of
land and little diversity right right
well lots of nazis anywhere is kind of
scary to me so speaking of nazis and uh
groups of nazis let's let's go right
back because i want to i want to touch
on a few points ontario uh here because
it seems significant uh like gabe said
earlier that there was no leaks from the
doj about his arrest which i think is
significant and i'm gonna ask a question
here uh also i think uh the nips the nip
the nip video was planned i believe that
was planned not just by the doj but
possibly by intario himself and the
reason why i think that and i'll tell
you here in a minute uh but i believe it
has to do with him being a snitch and
then also he wasn't at january 6th which
i think is significant so first off the
no leaks um i think that's significant
in that
that doj is keeping tight lips on any
indictments that may be coming with this
conspiracy rather it be with oath
keepers rather be with roger stone
rather be with proud boys especially
when we see ryder stone having ties to
not only uh this uh joshua james
character but also with the proud boys i
believe that that those tight lips and
roger stone not being indicted is very
very very significant um to the nips
thing
i think it should be tight tight lips
hard nips
that is perfect that is perfect i think
enrique dario has a new nickname tight
lips no no he would be loose lips hard
nips
tight lips loose lips and hard nips so
here's my take on the the nips video is
because enrico tario knows how this uh
being an informant works and a lot of
times when you're an informant you get
indicted you get formally indicted and
the indictment is actually to show
everyone around you that hey this person
may now be talking but also you want to
make it look like that that person may
not be cooperating as much as everyone
thinks like they want to create this
obscurity so in my mind in my mind the
video of him coming out and then making
a fool of him and then indicting him but
maybe he is already talking uh do you
think there's significance in that or is
that just some kind of thing that i'm
making up in my head
i genuinely don't know it could be
reading just a bit much into it because
in my personal experience with
likely informants
that have been at
like
weird dudes that have been at the
epicenter of everything that's ever gone
wrong for the militia movement and then
disappeared immediately
and got like new multi-million dollar
houses in wyoming by the time anyone
drops them down
nothing ever happens to them
like there were guys that were
on the interstellar bundys inner circle
at bundy ranch at malhur who were there
was one dude in particular who
was at bounty ranch and mouth you were
who was
claimed to be an army ranger but was
actually army intelligence and possibly
a cia contractor
and his entire record had been
fabricated and he was deeply involved
and was never charged and just
disappeared off the map there's
been plenty of people around stuart
who would try to like
probe like people that i knew into weird
conversations with leading questions
like what are you going to do
specifically
if uh you can write it down can you
write it down for me on the phone what
are you going to do if there's a tank
rolling down your street and they're
confiscating guns what's your plan
specifically in that hypothetical
scenario and everybody's just like
is this is this is this what some of the
delusion and
uh that stewart developed you think uh
throughout the years and maybe maybe uh
part of that makes him act the way he
acts you think i mean where he sees some
of this stuff happening and he hears
this stuff
yeah i think it definitely feeds into it
i mean just like a
there is an element of truth to
every single paranoid militia delusion
just like uh
they can't it's like chemtrails
conspiracy theory has its origins in the
very very real operation sea spray
during the world war
there is that element of truth and the
element of truth is that there if you're
in the militia movement there are
informants everywhere but a lot of those
informants
are like drowning men in a shipwreck and
they're just trying to grab at anything
they can and that's where
i'm seeing
like some potential similarities between
enrique tario
and uh
stuart is
i think stewart might have
been
compromised and been informing at some
point but he's always trying to get
clear
right that's my personal read so i don't
know if that arrest video of
tario was faked or right
right
so some news here uh this was as of two
hours ago okay um
uh scott mcfarlane i said alert in
motion uh seeking pre-trial jail of
enrique tario and capital riot
conspiracy case feds allege not only did
tario and stewart rhodes meet on january
5th
but
documentary film crew was present in the
garage and at one point picked up audio
of a person referencing the capital but
it looks like prosecutors also alleged
that tario posted on social media 20
minutes after accused proud boy dominic
pizzola smashed open capital window on
january 6
saying after i finish watching this i'll
make a statement about my arrest but for
now i'm enjoying the show
do what must be done
uh there's more obviously more inside of
this uh
this these trial documents but uh
i mean you know to go back to what you
were you were saying dakota yes they did
in fact meet because it is in fact on
these court documents and
wrong
yeah so yeah but january 5th
yeah they they met up they were in the
garage and now it looks like they have
audio recording of at least part of this
part of a conversation about the capital
you know that's pretty significant too
having considered what i said earlier
about that uh tario was not at january 6
he was not in the city of dc on january
6. so my assumption is in that story
that is breaking and it's just an
assumption here that they probably met
outside the city of dc somewhere else
the day before
um to do whatever talking or planning
that they were this was in downtown d.c
so they so he was indeed because he says
wasn't tario not allowed in dc because
of the burning thing right so tario was
released at approximately 5 pm on
january 5th after having been in order
to leave the district of columbia tario
did not immediately comply with the
order instead he traveled to an
underground parking garage located in
downtown washington dc where for
approximately 30 minutes he met with a
group of individuals that included elmer
stewart rhodes iii the founder leader of
the oath keepers a documentary film crew
was present in the garage and at one
point picked up audio that i just
referenced while in the parking garage
tario uh told another individual that he
had cleared all the messages on his
phone before he was arrested tario
further stated no one would be able to
get into his phone because there were no
uh because there were two steps to get
into it
yeah two-factor authentication can't
break two-factor authentication
[Laughter]
well he is a [ __ ]
and it says thereafter tario left the
district of columbia and traveled to
baltimore maryland that evening tario
used the phones of associates to make a
number of phone calls and to log back
into his encrypted messaging accounts
after having regained access to his
accounts tario assured his men that his
phones had not been compromised and taro
was subsequently added back into both
the mosd
leaders group and the new mosd members
what does that mosd stand for real quick
mosd stands for ministry of self-defense
according to these uh to this court doc
like everything is laid out in this
court document it's 21 pages of the the
the tension
uh memorandum but we'll try to link to
it too uh yeah yeah
in here it says you know december 19th
is when the plans were announced to
protest dc for the certification and
then beginning in late december 2020
tario created a new chapter for the
proud boys referred to as the ministry
of self-defense or mosd he described the
mosd as a national rally planning
chapter that would include only hand
selected members tario and the other
mosd leaders imposed a command and
control structure on this new chapter
tario identified the mosd leaders and
organized them into operational council
and marketing council and then here's
the thing on january 6th his men the
leaders and members of the mosd were on
the front of the crowd who unlawfully
breached the capitol grounds and overran
police lines meant to protect the
capital on his occupants so
does that answer your question to code
on the mom
that's pretty important okay well tell
us the importance real quick before we
just just that uh
there was a
just
there was a special chat room set aside
for
the
central planning of
r of rallies and that was operating as a
cover for
most likely of the planning of the
breaching of the capital and what's
starting to
emerge here is
it kind of looks to me like oath keepers
and proud boys were given parallel
missions is that like as like as a like
a redundancy measure if one failed the
other could continue yes and that's
where you have the proud boys are the
experienced street brawler guys who are
expected to be at the forefront
of any attack they're the ones who get
the crowd into the building to create
chaos and then of course you have the
stack
that's going in and looking for the
offices of certain politicians so that
stat going interior
had a mission and then the qrf on the
outside was going to be activated as
soon as there was cover
for bringing weapons into dc and going
live fire
so at every so
because in order for the entire plan to
go off once there is an antifa there to
brawl with
somebody has to smash open the capital
doors somebody has to break open the
windows
and get people inside to create chaos
for other groups to operate in and that
is where proud boys would have had a lot
more street brawling experience
than oath keepers because oathkeepers
always hangs back that's why they didn't
get top billing when the proud boys did
they got a little bit of a cold sorry if
i'm doing going a little bit friend
rusher audio on the audio
no it's okay but uh
it's like oath keepers is always hanging
back in the background with a shitload
of guns and riot gear super ready to go
but never in the mix because that
stewart rhodes that's his modus operandi
he's the big tough guy he's gonna get it
done but he never gets
where he can get punched right oh yeah
he's just
just further like far enough away where
if someone were to punch she would be
out of the line
yeah yeah just a little bit back wearing
all the [ __ ]
but like
ready to go
for being the super for being as [ __ ]
survival a superhero
so in other words so in other words
we're talking about cosplay here yes
but
uh
i mean the uh
the sa were cosplayers until hitler
power
the assets were the greatest cosplayers
in history
until they were put in charge of
genocide and did a bang-up job
so i feel like when people say as
cosplayers like talking about patriot
front like yeah
like by the standards of like historical
reenactment people
and like hema people and [ __ ] uh
like
patriot front or vanguard america's
little shield walls amateurish and
ridiculous and their training videos are
[ __ ] ridiculous but they are training
and organizing and that's very very bad
um right a bunch of oath keepers might
look ridiculous fully kitted out in
their tactical gear but they're showing
up
as
an organized group that's done training
to go do something which is extremely
bad and as ridiculous as it might seem
it'd be a huge mistake
to discount it just because it looks
silly well i think i agree with you and
i'd love to i'd love to talk to you more
about the essay and the ss because a lot
of people don't know the difference and
they don't know that the essay was the
unsuccessful group that hitler uh they
had to have tried to have a violent take
over the government and that's why he
went to prison and then he ended up when
he took over the government those were
the first he killed was the essay those
were the first murdered those of the
that was a leadership that were
around on a relatively equal footing
with hitler when he was beginning his
movement that is where there actually
was
factually for a little bit of time ace
actually socialist wing
of the nazi party that was uh or at
least a left-leaning wing of the nazi
party i believe in some socialism that
was strasserism and those are the first
people to die because it's always
the brown shirts that were it was like
like when somebody makes it big and as
an athlete or as a musician and suddenly
they're making the big bucks
their first wife who stuck with them
during the ramen noodle years
gets ditched for a trophy wife
immediately that's how dictators treat
their supporters
i like the ramen noodle years yeah
of hardcore political brawlers and
supporters that see you into power
become a liability once you're there
especially the leadership so you cut off
everything you can't use
and you fold the survivors into the new
group that is
better and classier and more stiffed up
and they got hugo boss uniforms they
think you're god
and they're 100 on board and undyingly
loyal well i let's let's try to keep
these fools in the ramen noodle years
let's try to keep them there let's try
not to advance them at all dakota thank
you for joining us i appreciate come
back anytime we want to keep talking you
as the the news develops as it just did
right here on here uh thank you very
much make sure to follow make sure to
follow dakota on twitter and uh follow
his mom go to their website also uh look
at some of the books um i i've been
meaning to read the
the first i i believe it's like the
first
uh i read the first draft but i think
she has another piece that she's put on
the website yeah she's got an outtake
that doesn't really fit in well with the
flow of the story that's just a little
bit about uh so it's like a short story
in other words yeah being uh snuck into
um
a law firm
to cover for to cover for stewart in the
most ridiculous mundane way possible
great well so everyone go go follow go
follow the code to go follow tasha and
go to the website uh the website's on uh
tasha's uh uh twitter page we'll put it
up here so yeah that's gonna be uh the
uh that girl tasha blog spot and it's
gonna be uh batgirl tasha
at twitter and i'm dakota v adams on
twitter thanks dakota for joining us
my friend uh everyone stick around we'll
be right back after these messages